la gran pesadilla para los habitantes de
nicopol viene de la planta nuclear de
zapatilla que está a mis espaldas en
control de las fuerzas rusas muchos
temen de que pueda haber una posible
radiación especialmente desde la
destrucción de la presa de cajobca el
gobierno entregado a cada uno de los
habitantes una píldora que tienen que
tomarse en el momento que se sospeche
que haya radiación
nuestra vida es cada vez más miedosa
porque la planta nuclear Está al lado
Esto es lo que nos da más miedo pero
tampoco hay agua y somos viejos tenemos
que venir a recoger agua de aquí pero no
podemos hacerlo todos los días es
físicamente difícil para nosotros parte
de la población que se ha quedado en
icopol son personas mayores que ya
tuvieron que vivir durante el invierno
con grandes cortes de Electricidad
solamente tenían luz pocas horas al día
y ahora que llegan los días más
calurosos del año no tienen agua y
tienen que pasar su tiempo haciendo cola
esperando que lleguen los tanques con
agua potable gracias a Dios sobrevivimos
a los cortes de electricidad Pero ahora
no tenemos agua y es difícil muy difícil
ya no sabíamos acostumbrado de nuevo a
las condiciones normales de vida y ahora
ya nos las han quitado de nuevo
especialmente para aquellos que tienen
pequeños es muy difícil vivir sin agua
empezaron a atacar esta zona porque
creyeron que distribuíamos agua
tenemos agua recogida en la bañera y la
guardamos cuidadosamente allí Pero
sabemos que no podrá durar por mucho
tiempo
Esta es una de las tantas casas ubicadas
a lo largo del río y este es uno de los
sectores más atacados por las fuerzas
rusas el 17 18 de junio hubo ataques en
la cercanías una persona murió otra
quedó herida pero lo que más preocupa a
esta familia es la escasez de agua
porque necesitan de lo que cultivan para
sobrevivir en verano